okay let's get to audience questions for
the week I've got some interesting ones
to discuss with you the first one is
about Donald Trump's fundraising for
2020 and I got this question in a few
different formats and the gist of it is
David how is it that Donald Trump is
raising such insanely huge amounts of
money for 2020 and there's a lot of
misinformation spreading about this
which I want to sort of break down for
you today number one a lot of the
reports of Trump's fundraising for 2020
are very overblown and there's a couple
different story lines that have been
circulating one is that Trump is raising
more money than all of the Democratic
candidates combined that's just flat-out
untrue Donald Trump right now has
roughly the same cash on hand as Bernie
and Kamala Harris two of the bigger
democratic fundraisers so far but it's
important to understand that aside from
it being incorrect that dropped Trump
has raised as much money as all of the
dem candidates which he hasn't a lot of
trumps fundraising has happened number
one because of these joint fundraising
agreements with the Republican Party
which the eventual Democratic nominee
will likely already have with the
Democratic Party but we're not seeing
the full force of that happening right
now because there are so many Democratic
candidates currently in the mix and
number two you have to understand that
Trump has been raising money for 2024
way longer than any Democratic candidate
remember that the day before the day of
the inauguration I believe it was of
Donald Trump's inauguration he
officially filed for reelection and I
told you then it's funny thinking back
to whatever the date was January 21 22
of 2017 this allowed Trump to
immediately start raising money for 2020
so Trump has a bunch of cash on hand
right now but he's been raising money
for more than two years at this point in
time because of that very early
re-election filing there's also just a
kind of simple mathematical thing that's
important to consider which is that if
you donate to Trump in January of 2017
or in March of 2017 or in May
of 2018 or whatever you're already
donating to the general election in the
sense that okay William weld is
challenging Trump for the Republican
nomination you may see a bit of a
Republican primary but in all likelihood
if you know so early that you can donate
to the candidate who will be on the
national election ballot that is going
to generate a lot more contributions
than primary donations where you might
end up donating to somebody and
mathematically most of the people
running on the Democratic side are not
going to be on the ballot on in November
of 2020 because they will have lost the
primary so that is just a mathematical
reality people often are much more
willing to donate to someone they know
will be on the ballot in the end then
one of 15 or however many Democratic
candidates there are who might not even
make it to the general election so those
are all sort of structural realities the
other thing that's really important to
mention and this is where we get sort of
into the qualitative stuff rather than
the quantitative with Trump's
fundraising is that Trump does a lot of
stupid things and he has a lot of
boneheaded people around him but he has
very cleverly used all of the scandals
which are correct scandals they're real
scandals they're all based on real stuff
that Trump did he's been doing a really
good job of framing them as fake and
then saying help me raise money in order
to fight back against the fake news the
witch-hunt Moeller probe which of course
confirmed in the Moller report almost
every major investigative story
surrounding the Moller probe trump for
two years now has been saying witch-hunt
illegal investigation partisan
investigation give me money to help me
fight back against it that is extracted
a lot of money from Trump's base
claiming to be the victim asking people
to donate on the basis of the Dems are
stopping me from building the wall when
in reality Republicans also were not
particularly thrilled with a lot of
Trump's wall related funding proposals
that is actually you've got a hand that
the Trump he's actually done that and
really it's the people around him
they've done that pretty effectively
none of this by the way changes that
it's ultimately going to be a turnout
election Trump won with 77,000 votes in
three states if the left can slightly
increase turnout in those key states
that could have gone one way or the
other it's over Trump has no chance if
the left can't do that if the enthusiasm
that was created when Donald Trump was
elected and inaugurated has sort of
faded and doesn't translate into people
actually getting out to vote if Trump
keeps successfully playing the victim
and it works and it keeps him raising
money then Trump gets reelected and as
I've done mathematically as I've
mathematically analyzed before Trump can
win reelection with only 18 to 19
percent of the voting public not of all
voters of people who actually vote but
of the voting age public Trump can win
reelection with only 18 or 19 percent of
their vote based on half the country not
voting
and based on the electoral college
system that we have so if Trump raising
a lot of money makes you realize we've
got to get our you-know-what together
for 2020 then buy it by all means that's
a good thing just understand some of
those fundraising numbers are pretty
overblown